Your first task was to fill in the rest of the code of this for loop down here.
So the first thing that we changed is the wood density.
The new wood density is going to be equal to the old wood density
minus the time step times the burn rate.
Since remember the burn rate is really just the time derivative of the wood density.
Now for the change in temperature. Of course, we start with the initial temperature.
And then we add to it h times a bunch of stuff.
Now all of this code is just taking into account those four factors that we were saying
influenced the change in temperature.
So the first thing we have right here you can see is a 2D heat equation.
And this is actually implemented using the finite difference scheme.
After this, we also take into account heat loss and then the wind and then also the combustion.
Now going up to the top of our wildfire function,
let's talk about this initial distribution of wood density.
This first line right here is just a translation of that mathematical expression
I had written out for you.
The y intercept of the point that we're considering is just equal to some y value
minus the slope that we're given times x and actually this xy
is the xy that we're talking about at this moment.
That means that the wood density then is equal to wood value 1.
Well, a bunch of typos. Well that's a problem. Let's fix that right now.
See everyone makes mistakes. This should be wood 2. This should be wood 1.
Okay now that all of that is fixed we have the wood density at our point xy
is equal to wood 1 the maximum possible wood density plus all of this.
This is the difference between wood 2 and wood 1.
It's that range in which w is allowed to vary
across the terrain divided by the difference between intercepts.
So you remember on the graph that I showed you earlier.
This graph right here actually.
That is the slope of this line since wood density here is on the y axis
and the intercept is actually on the x axis.
If we take the difference in wood density divided by the difference in intercept
we get the slope of this pink line right here.
So now you can see that we have the slope of that pink line times the intercept of the line
up to the point we're considering is on minus intercept 1.
So this is really just using point slope form to calculate w.
Remember, we only want w to range between wood 1 and wood 2.
So this line restricts it to that range. Now let's look at the plot we get.
So finally a graph of our forest.
In both images, we're looking at the xy square of terrain that we've been talking about.
Here we're graphing the temperature shown by these different colors,
and here we're graphing the density of wood.
Now unfortunately this is only a 50 x 50 pixel image.
If we wanted to see what's happening with much better resolution, we should use 200 x 200.
Unfortunately my computer is not cooperating so we're going to have to settle
for this less perfect image.
Even though this isn't really a perfect picture,
you can still tell that the wood has been depleted in the center.
The density of wood is very low right here compared to the rest of the area
where the fire hasn't spread yet.
You can also see that as we wanted the density of the wood does vary along lines like this.
In the 200 x 200 image, you would be able to see that the wood had been
very depleted in the center and that the fire had marched out the rim of this area.
We can kind of tell that there is sort of a red circle around here.
However, we'd be able to better that the fire is moving slower,
and it's less hot in the area where there's less wood.
The spreading the fire is way to slow on this image and one reason for that is that
the heat is averaged over larger pixels so actually not lowering the temperature
reached the temperature of ignition in a lot of places.
I hope you found talking about wildfires as exciting as I have.
Awesome job on this problem and throughout the entire course.
I hope you're excited for the final exam.
I think it'll give you a great look at a ton of different examples
not just from the material we've learned about but also from some new kinds of applications.